una crisis carcelaria que pasa por el
hacinamiento y el crimen organizado
y es que aunque ecuador tiene una
capacidad máxima para 28 mil presos hoy
cuenta con más de 35 mil en algunas
celdas de cuatro metros cuadrados
permanecen hasta 14 reclusos como fue
corroborado durante visitas de
funcionarios de la unión europea y no un
preso por cada ocho metros cuadrados
como sugiere el estándar internacional
las cárceles en el ecuador están
convertidas en estructuras porosas y las
organizaciones del crimen organizado
avanzan mejoran su sofisticación en
términos de organización mientras del
estado carece de un sistema de
inteligencia estratégico que le permita
prever y neutralizar este tipo de
eventos el programa de asistencia contra
el crimen transnacional organizado de la
unión europea destino 2,6 millones de
dólares para hacerle frente a este
problema buscando una acomodación óptima
de los reos y realizando una
clasificación de los perfiles más
violentos a nivel carcelario se entregó
el control de todas las cárceles a la
policía hoy la policía nacional está
administrando todo el sistema carcelario
por lo tanto como entran armas a las
cárceles cómo se permite la fuga de
presos si es que se supone que hay
anillos de seguridad a cargo de fuerzas
armadas y policía nacional
las organizaciones internacionales han
sugerido al gobierno ecuatoriano
ingresar a centros penitenciarios solo a
delitos que se consideren como un
peligro para la sociedad así como la
construcción de nuevas cárceles donde no
se exceda la capacidad de prisioneros
sugieren que sean establecimientos
pequeños para tener un mayor control de
todo el recinto